[Music]
welcome back so this is our warm up
lecture of how to use the fast Fourier
transform in Python and so in this
lecture what I'm gonna do is create a
really simple dataset which is just the
sum of two sine waves of different
frequencies we're gonna add noise to
that dataset and we're gonna use the
fast Fourier transform to pull out kind
of the the structure and the data and D
noise okay so in this example we're
gonna see what the fast Fourier
transform is how do you apply it to data
and how you actually do that in Python
okay so this is the code the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna create our
signal with two frequencies so we're
gonna have a time step of 0.001 samples
per second and we're gonna have a data
set that goes from time 0 to time 1
which is the sum of this sine wave with
frequency 50 Hertz and this sine wave
with frequency 120 Hertz okay so we're
gonna add up those two pure-tone sine
waves and then what we're going to do is
we're going to take that clean signal F
and we're gonna add a bunch of random
white noise to it okay and in fact this
is actually quite a lot of random noise
so if I add up two sine waves then kind
of the maximum variation I can get as
plus or minus 2 I'm adding white noise
with magnitude 2.5 so this is a lot of
random noise and now I'm just gonna plot
both the clean signal and the noisy
signal here so you can see here this is
a data set in time and this is the
signal in white here we have the clean
two tone sine wave with just 50 Hertz
plus 120 Hertz and red is the noisy data
once you add that Gaussian white noise
on top okay and so we're gonna play a
game we're going to act like someone
sent us this red data and didn't tell us
anything about the low dimensional
structure that this was just two sine
waves added up so we're only going to
get the red data and we're going to have
to infer kind of what the clean D noise
signal would be using this fast Fourier
transform okay
so the first thing we do is we actually
compute the fast Fourier transform
okay and in in pretty much every
programming language this is super
simple because it's so fundamental and
you want to use it all the time they've
made it as simple as possible so in PI
you just run this FFT command so numpy
fft fft and you give it the data f and
the length of that data and how many
data points there are and it returns f
hats okay so just to remember we have
our data F which is an a vector we're
gonna run it through this FFT command
and we're gonna get this vector F hat
Fourier coefficients ok these are
complex valued Fourier coefficients that
tell you how much kind of magnitude what
are the magnitude and phase of the sine
and cosine components of increasing
frequency you would have to add up to
get this data set okay so these are
complex values with a magnitude and a
phase the magnitude tells you how
important that particular frequency is
the phase tells you if it's more cosine
or sine and and what mixture okay and
once you have this Fourier transform now
what we're going to do is compute the
power spectral density the PSD which is
just f hat times the conjugate of F hat
divided by N and so I like to think of
this if you take if you take lambda some
complex number lambda times lambda
conjugate this is essentially going to
give you the magnitude of lambda squared
if this is a complex number I'm just
going to write this out for you lambda
equals a plus IB so lambda conjugate
would be a minus IB and so if you
multiply lambda times lambda bar you get
a squared minus I squared times B
squared a squared plus B squared
okay so lambda times lambda bar or
lambda conjugate just gives you the
magnitude of lambda squared and that's
what we're doing here with with F hat so
we're computing the magnitude of each
Fourier coefficients squared and we're
going to get a vector
of powers at each frequency okay and you
can convince yourself that if this is a
function of time then these each each
frequency has units of per second these
will be in units of Hertz and so you can
convince yourself that if I take F hat
times its conjugate this will have kind
of units of power so this is the power
spectral density that we're computing
here then I have to compute this vector
of frequencies so each entry in here
corresponds to a particular frequency
from low frequency to high frequency and
so I have to actually build a vector of
all of those frequencies in this this
freak vector and now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to plot my power
spectrum the magnitude of F squared F
hat squared versus the frequency in
units of Hertz okay so I'm going to run
this code and so we have our data noisy
and clean and now what we see is our
power spectral density our power
spectrum as a function of frequency so
please for those of you at home actually
label your x and y axes okay
this bottom plot is the power spectrum
and it has the x axis is in Hertz okay
so it's in frequencies and the y axis
tells you how much power is in each of
those frequencies in the red data okay
and so right off the bat what you see
here is that even though the signal is
noisy the power spectrum has to
super-clean Peaks one at 50 Hertz and
another at 120 Hertz okay so that tells
you that most of the power in this red
signal even though it's pretty noisy is
in 50 Hertz and 120 Hertz and then
there's a bunch of noise in this noise
floor that's contributing to the jitter
on the data and so what that tells us is
that you can actually filter this data
so you could actually you could actually
draw a line at some value I'm gonna pick
a hundred and any Fourier coefficient
that's smaller than 100 I'm just gonna
zero it out and any Fourier coefficient
that's larger than 100 I'm gonna keep it
and then we're gonna inverse Fourier
transform and try to reconstruct our
clean we're gonna try to denoise the red
signal and get a clean signal with just
these two frequencies okay I'm gonna
write that out here what we're gonna do
is we're going to filter we're gonna
literally take all of our values that
have have F magnitude squared less than
100 and we're gonna kill all of those
terms so we're gonna get F hat filtered
okay these are still Fourier
coefficients and then I can take the
inverse fast Fourier transform it's
literally the IFFT command and I'm gonna
get F filtered and this is gonna be my
filtered time series it's gonna have
units of time okay so that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna kill all these
small 4u coefficients and then we're
gonna inverse Fourier transform and
again this is quite easy to do in Python
what we're gonna do is get this indices
vector by saying indices equals PSD
greater than 100 it's literally gonna
take that whole power spectral density
vector and it's gonna check every
element if it's bigger than 100 if it's
smaller than 100 it'll give us 0 and if
it's bigger than 100 it'll give a 1 so
this indices vector will be a big vector
mostly of zeros because most of these
are smaller than 100 and it'll have two
entries of one at the entry
corresponding to 50 Hertz and 120 Hertz
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take my power spectrum and I'm gonna
multiply it by that indicee vector and
it's gonna zero out all of the indices
that have small for a coefficient and
it's only gonna keep those that have
power greater than 100 okay that's going
to be this F hat kind of clean here and
then I'm gonna inverse Fourier transform
to get my filtered signal and I'm gonna
plot that for you okay so I'm gonna run
this and then finally I'm gonna plot
everything together okay good so
remember we had this red noisy data we
Fourier transformed it we realized that
we could get rid of all of the small
Fourier coefficients so we manually
zeroed those out and we only kept these
two white Peaks these filtered peaks at
50 and 120
I didn't tell the computer that it was
50 Hertz and 120 it just picked whatever
values were bigger than some threshold
okay and then when you inverse Fourier
transform the signal you recover this
white signal here is the filtered signal
that corresponds to what is underneath
all of this noise and the original data
it's a little hard to see because the
the scales are different but this is in
fact actually the sum of 50 Hertz and
120 Hertz that's in this white signal up
here okay so this is super useful this
is just a toy example to show you if you
have data you can first compute its
Fourier transform which gives you an
interesting and intuitive interpretation
in terms of the power spectrum this
power spectral density function which is
just the magnitude of F squared at each
frequency this has units of Hertz in the
x-axis and then you can use that in this
case to filter noisy data by finding
whatever Peaks are above some noise
floor zeroing out everything below and
then inverse Fourier transforming 2d
noise the signal okay so this is super
useful you can start playing with this
right away it's really really easy to
compute the Fourier transform the power
spectrum and start playing around with
data okay thank you